بما انه ذكرنا الفنانه الرائعه شيرين اللي
انا من عشاق جدا كلنا من عشاق اليوم ما
شفت الها انها فعلا الها عوده كبيره
وموجوده على المسرح وهذا المكان اللي يلوق
لها
محبه وجدا عاطفيا وذكرت باللقاء انه انت
كنت من الناس يلي
موجوده بجانبها بالاوقات الصعبه بطريقه ما
فشو تحبين تقولين لشيرين اقول لها ان انا
واحده من معجبينك يا شيرين انت الفنانه
عظيمه وصوت مميز جدا
وتاريخك الكبير وعمره ما هيتاثر باي حاجه
فرحانه ان انت موجوده على المسرح وبنشاطك
جدا جدا ومستنيين منك كل ما هو جديد ورائع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات